Yesterday, after Donald Trump abruptly tweeted
out no second Corona virus stimulus after
conversations with Mitch McConnell and other
lawmakers, the speaker of the House, Nancy
Pelosi, got on a phone call with House Democrats
and they were talking about Donald Trump tweeting
out, we're not doing a second stimulus, which
seems like it seems like the last opportunity
Trump had to do something to actually gain
some votes in this upcoming election.
And Nancy Pelosi suggested or wondered whether
Donald Trump's use of the steroids dexamethasone
for treatment of his coronavirus might be
impacting Donald Trump's decision making ability.
Because even for the standards that we have
come to expect for Donald Trump, his behavior
is out of control.
And last night hit and indeed, Donald Trump
appeared to have had a steroid induced manic
episode on Twitter.
If you imagine the scene at the White House,
which at this point, I don't know if the White
House is more like a psych ward or a biohazard
unit at this point.
I guess it's like a biohazard psych ward.
Donald Trump would not stop tweeting last
night things that make absolutely no sense.
And it is again raising questions about whether
Donald Trump is experiencing mania as a result
of the drugs he is on to treat Corona virus.
Now, as I told you earlier this week, it's
not just observers from the outside that have
these concerns.
Donald Trump junior, as Gabriel Sherman wrote
in Vanity Fair.
On Monday, Donald Trump junior reportedly
is worried that Donald Trump is manic and
wants to stage an intervention.
And as we've talked about before, corticosteroid
induced mania is not an uncommon side effect
from the drugs that Donald Trump has been
taking.
Donald Trump already has a tendency to have
this sort of updown manic and then depressed
periods or episodes.
And last night was completely crazy.
Okay, so look.
Look at what is going on.
And remember, this is not some obscure political
adviser or a podcast host.
This is the president of the United States
at seven, 41 p.m. Eastern last night.
Donald Trump tweeted, I have fully authorized
the total declassification of any and all
documents pertaining to the single greatest
political crime in American history, the Russia
hoax.
Likewise, the Hillary Clinton email scandal.
No redactions.
So it's a crazy tweet.
It's already wacky.
But then 40 minutes later, Donald Trump tweets
about these same documents which he supposedly
just declassified.
Trump tweets, quote, All Russia hoax scandal
information was declassified by me long ago.
What you just said, you're declassifying it
now.
Trump goes on to say.
Unfortunately for our country, people have
acted very slowly, especially since it is
perhaps the biggest political crime in the
history of our country.
Notice in neither tweet does Trump actually
say what crime was committed.
That's a theme.
But long ago you declassified it.
40 minutes earlier, he announced he was declassifying
these documents and 40 minutes later he says,
I actually declassified this stuff long ago.
People are even on the right concerned about
the mental state of Donald Trump and whether
this is being impacted by the steroids that
he is on.
It continued all night.
It kept going this morning, seemingly nobody
able to get Donald Trump under control.
The speculation is that this is literal roid
rage.
The president roid raging on Twitter for hours.
Trump projecting about Joe Biden saying, quote,
I just hope the voter understands that they
are all fake news, trying hard to push a man
that should never be president of our country.
It sounds like he's referring to himself there
in 2016, right wing media.
Eventually, when the Republican primary was
over, getting in line and pushing for Trump,
who should never have been president of the
United States.
Trump again a radically after stopping the
second Corona virus stimulus.
Just hours earlier, out of the blue, Trump
tweets, quote, If I am sent a stand alone
bill for stimulus checks.
Twelve hundred dollars, they will go out to
our great people immediately.
I am ready to sign right now.
Are you listening?
Nancy, this was just hours after he stopped
negotiations and said we're not doing a second
Corona virus stimulus again.
Is this some kind of roid rage?
Is Trump thinking clearly?
Did someone get to him and say which?
By the way, would have been good advice, Mr.
President.
Sir, as he likes to say, the stock market
imploded when you tweeted no second stimulus.
It was sort of like the last opportunity in
these 27, 28 years of yesterday.
Days before the election to do something good
for the American people and maybe maybe regain
some votes.
Maybe Trump realized, what am I doing?
I'll now tweet.
I would sign the stimulus checks making no
sense.
Trump then inventing a new number system,
tweeting eleven comma, double zero.
So that's not a I don't know what kind of
format that is.
One one comma zero zero North Carolina residents
get incorrect voter registration forms.
Two thousand L.A. County voters received faulty
ballots with no way to vote for president.
Many others throughout USA.
Here we go.
This will be the most corrupt election in
American history.
Then Trump again after saying, remember, no
more second stimulus tweets to demand stimulus
money for airlines.
Tweeting, quote, The House and Senate should
immediately approve twenty five billion dollars
for airline payrolls support and one hundred
thirty five billion dollars for paycheck protection
programs for small business.
Both of these will be fully paid for with
unused funds from the Caires Act.
Have this money.
I will sign now and then a tweet that is both
completely incoherent but very disturbing.
Donald Trump saying, quote, I don't even know
what this means.
So I had to constantly fight off all this
scum, achieve more than any other president
in first term.
And then they talk chaos.
They created crimes against me and this administration.
There are dozens more.
But the point here is Trump is more out of
control than usual.
And just imagine the scene that the White
House trump already difficult to control.
Trump now is on steroids, which can cause
mania, euphoria and delusions of grandeur.
And anyone who wants to go near Trump has
to wear wear full PPE based on a report that
we've gotten.
Why?
Because Trump has Corona virus and he is presumably
still contagious unless he actually has had
it for way longer than we've been told.
In which case he might be past the contagious
phase.
The only alternative to Trump still being
contagious is that they really lied about
when Trump first tested positive.
It is a man crumbling before our very eyes.
A new poll has him down 21.
So where are we right now?
We could be if we get the job done.
We could be getting to the end of this global
nightmare.
But it depends on you going out to vote.
It depends on me going out to vote.
Believe me, I'm going to vote.
I would crawl over broken glass to vote.
I would crawl over shards of, I don't know,
send me creative people.
Please send me some more metaphors.
I can use Akin to crawling over a glass to
vote.
I would like to be a loaded up with some good
ones for them.
For the last four weeks of this campaign,
we can move on to the end of this national
nightmare.
We have the opportunity.
There's 27 days to go